my heart stopped beating for a moment
like what if there's a journey over like
oh my god uh just finally the day come
and i'm getting better with this
beautiful lady
like look what i'm getting look who i'm
getting
what a dream come true
after nine years together and overcoming
major obstacles in the relationship
including a 30-year age difference i've
been with him for nine years
already i'm not going anywhere
90 day fiance stars jenny and sumit have
tied the knot
today is absolutely the happiest day of
my life and my life too
on sunday's finale of 90 day fiance the
other way summit got over his cold feet
and decided to marry jenny i will marry
you because i want to want to be with
you i don't want to lose you
i want to keep experiencing that love
i'm ready you are ready both are ready
and that's good
the lead-up to the i do's was dramatic
with submit blocking their marriage's
legal paperwork behind jenny's back he
said he did it because he was still
traumatized from his first arranged
marriage ending in a messy divorce
and well after jenny got upset and
threatened to go back to america he had
a change of heart my fear is what is
causing us problem and i feel maybe you
feel insecure now
and i don't want that because if you
start feeling insecure
means you are losing uh hope you are
losing trust on me
and that's i i cannot afford it because
that's the starting of the relationship
is going to a wrong direction
naturally jenny was thrilled and they
called the lawyer to get the paperwork
up and running again the original plan
was to get married in court and not in
the temple on the advice of his family's
astrologer but since jenny's visa was
running out they didn't have time to do
it in court but they said they would
still follow the astrologer's other
advice and not make it a big celebration
if the traditional indian marriage is a
sea then our marriage is just like a
bucket of water from that sea that's it
but it's our bucket water
later jenny revealed to her henna
artists that they chose not to tell his
parents they were getting married
summit's parents had previously said
they would no longer block their son
from marrying jenny
a lot has happened and
some improvements have been made
and so now i'm just
i'm happy that at least
everyone's trying you know and
everyone's willing to try
and that's what makes me happy but they
didn't exactly give them their blessing
to marry either we're just scared that
they'll
cause drama and stop it i know that it's
wrong not to tell his parents that he's
getting married it wasn't an easy
decision to make but samid and i have
been through so much and i don't really
trust them a hundred percent
what we're doing is very scary thing and
we feel bad
but if we don't do this if we don't go
and get married we're not going to be
together anymore i'm not going to be in
india our relationship's going to end
and we're just not willing to let that
happen
when e.t spoke with a couple ahead of
this season summit said he would marry
jenny with or without his parents
approval i always keep on trying as but
i can
and
after that like once i feel like that um
like i did all my efforts to convince
them to show them how happy i am with
jerry and that's what i want in my life
and after that if they don't understand
them no point and i
i think i will go ahead and journey in
order to get love i need to stay strong
and keep explaining you can keep
fighting for love keep showing people uh
that we are happy and that's most
important and when it came to their
wedding day jenny was super emotional
wow
just beautiful just amazing
i didn't think i would get this
emotional but wow
but wow
wow
i'm just overwhelmed i really am
very overwhelmed right now
i can't even believe this is happening
it's just
finally
well the two said i do and summit
admitted he was nervous about not
telling his parents
i want them to be a part of this
but i'm pretty sure if my parents will
come to know that we are getting married
they will show up and try to stop the
marriage i know that they will be angry
but i love this lady
i want to marry her i will be happy and
this is what i choose for myself
we don't know what our future holds but
only thing we know is that we're happy
together
and we're living our life the way that
we want to we made it that's all i can
say is man we made it
[Music]